the uk and its allies trained and
supported afghan special forces like
these
a vital partnership when going after
terrorists and taliban targets
but while their operations helped keep
the streets of the uk safe hundreds of
these afghan commandos say they're now
in danger on their own streets following
the taliban takeover
wanting to help this afghan accountant
living in birmingham is compiling a list
of elite troops who are desperate to
escape to britain
every single message that i receive is
that
we will be killed
we are living in hiding we are not in
our villages we are not in our homes
rafi was a former interpreter for
british special forces who fled the
decade ago
but he's put his new life on pause to
gather the names of some 400 afghan
commandos in need of help
they are the people who have served the
british government for 20 years and so
they deserve a life free from you know
fear of you know being killed by by any
terrorist group it's not only the
taliban the iss leaving them behind i
see it a
a
a failure of the uk government
a betrayal of these brave soldiers
and
they deserve duty to live a life of
dignity and and safety
also on his list are some 200 former
interpreters and other staff who worked
for the uk in afghanistan but didn't
make the evacuation flights either
rafi plans to share his list with the
government to pressure ministers into
action
one former interpreter in hiding in
kabul told me he couldn't reach the
airport to be evacuated last month
because of crowds and taliban
checkpoints
when i went on that day
the taliban they beat me with their
ak-47s
now we demand from the british
government if they could work on some
sort of third country evacuation
what's happening boris johnson has
pledged to help those left behind with
the ministry of defense saying its offer
to relocate anyone eligible will stay
open
another former interpreter whose
identity we're protecting is worried
about his father a one-time gardener for
uk forces in afghanistan who's still
stranded there
he said the taliban came into the
village because the taliban's everywhere
now in in afghanistan
he said to me i don't trust anymore i
don't i don't trust anymore just you i
mean i don't trust the the the
government the uk government because he
said
they they they have promised me so many
times but to look at that i'm still left
behind
for the special forces as well as fear
of capture many no longer have a job and
money is running short
it means time is running out for the uk
to make good on its word to rescue its
friends
debra haynes sky news